a return date for some clark county
school district students is confirmed
only moments ago thanks for joining us
at six i'm christian casares good
evening everybody i'm brian loftis ccsd
just sending out this memo to teachers a
short time ago
that will put some back in schools as
early as february 22nd
a news down reporter kristen drummond
joining us live from the newsroom with
the very latest
kristin well brian and christian that
february 22nd date was chosen to let
educators prepare for pre-kindergarten
through third grade students coming back
march 1st they'll start hybrid
instructional model
that's the mix of in-person and online
learning
this update comes after a new cdc study
recommends students returning to
buildings with certain precautions
giving some guidance and clarity about
this topic
i feel that they do need to get back
into regular school
but i just don't think this year jamie
johnson is the mother of three
ccsd students she's not ready to send
her children back in buildings
despite the recent cdc research
published online in the journal of the
american medical association
we've been this far already we might as
well just finish out the year
cdc scientists support school campuses
reopening but
only with proper prevention that
includes social distancing
wearing a mask better ventilation
indoors and adopting the hybrid model
to prevent overcrowding this entire
pandemic we've been told to trust the
science and
i'm one to believe that but some
educators like kenny belknap still want
the kovit 19 vaccine before stepping in
a building
as of right now i still have some
precautions i would like to at least get
the first shot to feel
a little bit better about it c-d-c
scientists looked at data from schools
in the u.s
and internationally that reopened for
in-person learning
the study says while school-related
covid19 cases have been reported
there has been little evidence that
schools have contributed meaningfully
to increased community transmission if
you have the option to
send your children back
would you take it not this year no i
don't believe so
hesitation as families wait and see what
ccsd decides to do next
this is the memo that cd ccsd sent out
to
educators now they say they want to
transition other grades to hybrid
learning this semester but
there is no timeline for when that may
happen reporting live in the newsroom
kristen drummond 8 news now